allez un peu de culture avant de se
quitter alors que les musées sont fermés
les galeries d'art privées elles sont
autorisées à ouvrir à tour la boîte
noire propose pour la douzième année
consécutive ces petits formats 0 tic 190
oeuvre qui mêle art et sensualité et qui
confirme que ce n'est pas la taille qui
compte
l'occasion d'un bouillon de culture
décalée et rafraîchissante durant cette
période morose
visite guidée avec florent clavel
surtout bien s'approcher derrière la
candeur de snoopy d'espiègles le petit
oiseau de vie mariage garder ou dénudés
soulor une gravure les ché pour cette
douzième édition des petits formats
l'érotisme et joueurs
téméraire aussi qu'ovide le frigidaire
jouer les trouble fête
jusqu'à cette autorisation d'ouverture
et ce coup de fil aux artistes finaliser
vos oeuvres aller acheter les cadres et
et du coup tout s'est fait relativement
vite et puis tout le monde ya mis du
sien ils sont tous venus m'aider
donc c'était plutôt sympa 18 créateurs
190 oeuvre du petit aux tout petits
formats de la peinture à la sculpture
chez les visiteurs pas de fausse pudeur
et ça me fait du bien parce que je
trouve ça très beau je trouve que
d'autre part ont encore de la famille
sublime donc tout l'expression du corps
de femme les beaucoup oui à l'entrée
j'ai reconnu goldorak quoi ça fait moins
rire parce qu'il va faire que je
m'habille maintenant goldorak sur le
marché de l'art érotique le phallus
reste dans une forme olympique
mais depuis quelques années la féminité
les artistes féminines prennent de plus
en plus leur place
elle ose plus montré le corps des femmes
et pas le corps académique comme comme
on le voyait jusqu'ici en art et ça
c'est une vraie évolution révolution et
elle n'hésite pas à sculpter à dessiner
des clitoris et je trouve que c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt bien parti au 21e
siècle il était temps l'érotisme sous
toutes ses formes et toutes ces tailles
c'est à voir jusqu'au 26 décembre à la
boîte noire